Transcriber: Mohammed Burghul
المدقّق: Hanaa Yehia
السلام عليكم
أنا فاطمة بنت أحمد أبو سريع
وعتمة
لا تعرفون عني شيئا اخر
لم يتم التعريف بمؤهلاتي العلمية
كما فعلوا الزملاء مع باقي زملاىي وزميلاتي
ربما بعضكم يعرفني مسبقاً
وربما بعضكم قرأ اسمي
وتعرف علي قليلاً
لكن
معظمنا الآن في مرحلة عتمة
العلاقات، أياً كان نوع العلاقات
تبدأ بمرحلة العتمة
فلنأخذ العلاقات الانسانية
ونصغر المدى قليلاً
ونجعلها علاقتنا الآن
نحن الآن في عتمة
ولن أقشع هذه العتمة
ولن أعرفكم
حتى تنقشع عتمة اللغات
نعم
هذه هي الطريقة
هي الطريقة الوحيدة
لسنا في تحدي، لا أبداً
لكن
يزعم البعض من متحدثي اللغات بمعنى
أنه يتحدث لغة ثانية وثالثة
أنه سيكون أفضل مني
في قشع العتمة
بين أي متحدثين آخرين
لا يفهمان بعضهما لأنه
يتحدثان لغتين غير مفهومتين
هو متقن، ربما
درجات اختباراته في هذه اللغات أفضل مني
ولكن، احزر ماذا
لن يكون يكون مترجماً أبداً.
أنا المترجم
وهو متحدث باللغة، مستخدم للغة
لماذا يا فاطمة ؟
نحن أفضل منك!
نعم، أنتم أفضل مني..
أنا تعلمت ثقافة هذه اللغة.
أنا قرأت عنها
أنا أعرف كيف أستخدم هذا المصطلح
في هذا السياق
نعم، ربما أخطئ أحياناً
في بعض التراكيب النحوية
التي تتقنها كمتقن للغة
لكنني لن أخطئ في السياق وهو الأهم
فلنتخيل مع بعضنا
جاك
شخصٌ ما اسمه جاك
جاء إلى الخليج العربي وتعلم اللغة العربية
متقناً جيداً للغة العربية
جاك يعلم أن في الخليج العربي
"يعطيك العافية" إيجابية
أنت تدعو لهذا الشخص
سافر جاك بالطائرة إلى المغرب العربي
جاك نزل في المطار وقال "يعطيك العافية"
الله يرحمك يا جاك
كان جاك شخصاً جيداً
هو أتقن اللغة لكن
لم يتقن ثقافة المغرب العربي
هو ليس مترجماً
هو متقن للغة
هو متحدث باللغة العربية
إذاً
"ولتعارفوا"
لماذا أنا فاطمة
ابنة السعودية العظمى
أريد التعرف على ثقافة
صيني ما
أو شخص ما في أقاصي أمريكا الجنوبية
لماذا أحتاج لذلك
لأن الله شبحانه وتعالى
قال في كتابه الكريم:
لم يخلقنا ونحن مختلفين
وهذه أصوات عشر لغات مختلفة
لا يفهم أحد منها أحداً
إلا لنتعارف
هل التقطتم صوتاً؟
أي صوت؟ أي لغة؟
هل فهمتم شيئاً؟ لا
لكن لو كان بينهم مترجمون
عشرة مترجمون لا أكثر بين اللغات
ستفهمونهم
كيف انتقلت العلوم ؟
بالترجمة.
لماذا انتقلت العلوم..
لماذا أصبحنا عالماً صغيراً فجأة؟
لأنه كان هناك مترجمون
بين هذا الشعب وذلك الشعب
نقل ثقافة هذا الشعب الى هذا الشعب
وحضارة هؤلاء إلى هؤلاء
فاستفدنا، أليس كذلك؟
انصهارٌ أم تكيّف
يزعم البعض
أنني عندما أتحدث بلغةٍ ما
يجب أن أكون
متلبسة لرداء هذه اللغة، بمعنى
أنا أتحدث اللغة الانجليزية
إذاً يجب أن تكون ثقافتي وحياتي
كالأشخاص في بريطانيا
أو ربما أستراليا
أو ربما أمريكا
نعم
أنا انصهرت مع هذه اللغة
أنا مترجمة لهم
إذاً يجب أن أنصهر معهم
وأتعلم جميع ما يفعلونه
وأكون كما هم
أليس كذلك ؟
لا وألف لا، ليس كذلك
تكيّف معهم
تكيّف لا أكثر
في هذه اللخظة التي تترجم فيها
أنت تلبس رداء سفير بين اللغتين
هو يتحدث، تنقل للآخر فقط
لا تتبنى آراء ولست مجبراً على تبني آراء
ربما تترجم إلى شخص بثقافة مضادة لثقافتك
بديانة أخرى تختلف عن دينك
فلماذا تتبنى الآراء ؟
إذاً لن أصبح مترجماً
لا، يمكنك أن تصبح مترجماً
بالتكيف فقط.
لأنه هذه هي الطريقة الصحيحة أصلاً
أتكيّف معهم
أتعلم عن ثقافة الآخر
كيف يأكلون كيف يشربون
يستغرب البعض
ما لهذا بهذا يا فاطمة
فقط تعلمي القواعد
اختبري ال IELTS
وجيبي ٦ وخلص مشينا
صح ؟
لا مو صح ترا
حتى طريقة الأكل والشرب والملابس
تهم ذلك
وخلينا لا ننسى جاك
ويعطيه العافية يا جاك
انقشعت العتمة عن مجال الترجمة
أصبحتم تفهمون ماذا يعني ترجمة
ظهر الضوء
حان الوقت لتنقشع العتمة بيني وبينكم
فاطمة بنت أحمد أبو سريع
حاصلة على بكالوريوس في الترجمة
من جامعة اليرموك في الأردن
حاصلة على الدبلوم
في تأهيل القيادات الشابة للحوار العالمي
من مشروع سلام
حاصلة على زمالة
في الحوار بين أتباع الأديان والثقافات
وأدرس الآن دبلوم مهني
في العلاقات العامة والإعلام